(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) Vamos aqui para mais uma análise prática, então,
de um imóvel que está indo a leilão
excrediticial.
Separei esse apartamento aqui, agora na Barra da
Tijuca, no Rio de Janeiro.
Da mesma forma, a leiloeira apresenta o valor
do primeiro leilão, segundo leilão, endereço, metragem, distribuição
interna, área de lazer, número da matrícula do
imóvel e o cartório de registro de imóveis
que está responsável por esse imóvel lá no
Rio de Janeiro.
Indicrução na Prefeitura para levantar débitos de IPTU.
Vamos aqui de pronto fazer essa pesquisa.
IPTU Rio de Janeiro Débitos.
Aqui no cantinho, a gente tem a certidão
de situação fiscal do imóvel.
Emissão de certidão, inscrição imobiliária, só copiar, deixa
eu ver se veio tudo.
Veio.
Colocar um código, consultar.
Não quero imprimir,
quero só analisar ali.
Então está aqui, o endereço, estrada do engenho
d'água, 1401, apartamento 601, bloco 3.
Só para confirmar, apartamento 601, bloco 3, estrada
do engenho d'água.
O nome da proprietária, Fabiana Martins, provavelmente é
o nome da devedora, que ainda está no
nome dela.
Vamos abrir o edital aqui para ver.
Sim, Fabiana Martins de Souza, Fabiana Martins de
Souza.
Não há débitos inscritos em dívida ativa, então
não tem qualquer débito de IPTU.
Já matamos essa análise.
Seguir aqui para a matrícula consolidada, que é
o que a gente sempre precisa analisar com
calma.
Matrícula está aqui, número da matrícula, nono cartório
de imóveis, começa sempre com a descrição completa
do bem, apartamento 601, bloco 3 do prédio
em construção.
Ainda era em construção na época que abriram
essa matrícula 2016, estrada do engenho d'água.
Aí vem trazer aqui toda a metragem, toda
a descrição do imóvel, a inscrição fiscal e
o proprietário que era construtor na época.
A verbação número 1 traz informações internas do
cartório.
A verbação número 2, memorial de incorporação.
Isso aqui é dado da construção do próprio
condomínio.
A verbação número 3, afetação.
Patrimônio de afetação serve para garantir que aquele
empreendimento será entregue e também para passar segurança
para quem está comprando aquele empreendimento.
Então, quando tem lá uma construtora construindo determinado
empreendimento, a construtora vai afetar a parte do
patrimônio que ela precisa para finalizar aquele empreendimento
e, assim, garantir que nenhuma dívida dela vai
respaldar naquele patrimônio que ela está afetando, ou
seja, separando para finalizar aquele empreendimento.
Então, é uma garantia de que, de fato,
aquele empreendimento será entregue.
A verbação número 3, então, afetação, que é
o patrimônio separado ali para construir esse empreendimento.
A verbação número 4, para fazer constar que
ficam proibidos a captação e uso de água
subterrânea provenientes desse lote e sem entorno para
quaisquer fins.
Isso aqui é uma resolução, isso aqui é
uma verbação ali de alguma proibição ambiental, segundo
essa licença ambiental aqui que foi concedida para
esse empreendimento.
A verbação número 5, cancelou aqueles termos de
obrigação lá da verbação número 1, era algo
interno ali do próprio cartório.
A verbação número 6, aditamento para constar que
a área foi classificada como área reabilitada para
uso declarado, conforme decisão do CONAMA, que é
um órgão ambiental.
A verbação número 7, hipoteca cedular.
Hipoteca cedular em primeiro grau do imóvel dado
por CAPA Empreendimentos, que já está anteriormente qualificado,
já que é o proprietário desse imóvel, em
favor do Itaú.
Basicamente, hoje em dia, e esse imóvel aqui
é um imóvel recente, essa matrícula é de
2018, a gente só encontra hipoteca realmente de
construtora fazendo algum empréstimo ali com garantia de
hipoteca com algum banco.
Desde que existe a alienação fiduciária, basicamente a
hipoteca não é mais utilizada para banco emprestar
dinheiro e tomar como garantia um imóvel de
um particular, já que hoje em dia os
bancos fazem esse tipo de contrato com garantia
realmente por alienação fiduciária quando a gente trata
de particulares.
Agora, com construtoras, os bancos ainda costumam utilizar
a hipoteca.
Então, basicamente, hoje em dia, a gente só
encontra hipoteca para construtora e para imóvel de
particular ou pessoa jurídica que não tem ali
como finalidade a construção de novos empreendimentos, os
bancos costumam colocar realmente a garantia da alienação
fiduciária.
Então, hipoteca aqui porque a própria construtora para
construir empreendimento não tinha todo o capital necessário,
fez uma hipoteca então com o Itaú, nesse
caso, para levantar esse dinheiro e passou como
garantia esses imóveis.
Averbação número 8, a convenção de condomínio desse
próprio condomínio que foi construído.
Averbação número 9, a construção para averbar na
matrícula instruída pela certidão a construção do imóvel
tendo sido oferecido o Habits pela prefeitura.
Averbação número 10, retificação da averbação 9 para
constar que a data do Habits é de
outubro de 2017, não como constou lá anteriormente.
Averbação número 11, é um editamento para a
verbação número 7.
A verbação número 7 é essa aqui da
hipoteca entre a construtora e o Itaú.
Então, editou ali os termos da hipoteca constando
novos prazos para amortização dessa dívida.
Averbação número 12, para editar a convenção de
condomínio.
Averbação número 13, para cancelar a hipoteca da
verbação 7, ou seja, tinha uma hipoteca, não
existe mais a hipoteca.
O credor, que no nosso caso aqui específico
era o Itaú, determinou o cancelamento da hipoteca,
provavelmente pela quitação integral daquela dívida.
Inclusive, consta que em virtude da quitação dada
pelo credor Itaú Unibanco.
Contrato de compra e venda da Capa Empreendimentos,
que até então era a proprietária única, a
proprietária que já teve esse imóvel, com a
Fabiana Martins de Souza, os dados da Fabiana,
pelo preço de 312 mil, foi realizada em
dezembro de 2018.
Aqui já consta no registro 15, a própria
alienação fiduciária, que a Fabiana fez com o
Santander.
E aí vem trazendo os dados aqui do
Santander também, a dívida que ficou garantida foi
de R$ 248.100, informa também que
o valor de avaliação para leilão público é
de R$ 320 mil, que passa por
correção monetária até a data efetiva da realização
do leilão.
Inscrição fiscal, o número que o imóvel está
inscrito lá na Prefeitura, que a gente usa
para buscar os débitos de PTU, a gente
já fez essa busca, o leilão já tinha
destacado esse número para facilitar os interessados a
fazer essa pesquisa.
E o cancelamento da verbação de afetação.
Na verdade, essa verbação de afetação até nem
existiria mais, porque era uma verbação de afetação
da própria construtora para garantir que o patrimônio
necessário para construir esse empreendimento estava separado, então
resguardado lá, passando segurança para quem estava comprando
esse empreendimento na planta.
Com a venda para a Fabiana, automaticamente a
gente não falava mais de patrimônio de afetação,
já que o imóvel não era mais a
construtora, mas está aqui também a verbação 17,
cancelamento dessa afetação.
A verbação 18 é a intimação.
Intimação da fiduciante, que é a devedora fiduciante
Fabiana, anteriormente qualificada, realizada através de digital de
intimação publicada por meio eletrônico em 9 de
dezembro de 2020, através da Central de Serviços
Eletrônicos dos Registradores de Imóveis, conforme disposto, traz
aqui artigos da lei, artigos do provimento lá
do Rio de Janeiro, para que ela purgasse
a mora no prazo de 15 dias, contado
da terceira e última publicação desse edital.
O que aconteceu com esse edital aqui?
Essa notificação para purgar a mora, ela é
feita pessoalmente, então o cartório vai lá pessoalmente
notificar o devedor para purgar a mora.
Quando o cartório não encontra o devedor, vai
até o endereço do imóvel e não encontra
o devedor, aquela dívida não pode ficar esperando
a hora que o devedor vai aparecer, aquela
cobrança tem que seguir.
Então, se o devedor não atualizou ali o
seu endereço com o credor, é um erro
do devedor, seria uma obrigação do devedor atualizar
o seu endereço para que o credor conseguisse
encontrá-lo.
Então, não fez para que a dívida não
fique o tempo todo esperando, é feita a
publicação de edital para publicar nos veículos públicos
que aquela notificação está acontecendo, e aí sim
começar a contar o prazo de 15 dias.
Então, nesse caso, foi o que aconteceu com
a Fabiana, não conseguiram encontrar a Fabiana nos
endereços que ela disponibilizou ali para o credor,
até do próprio imóvel que ela comprou com
financiamento, para a dívida não ficar esperando e
o credor não tem a obrigação de ficar
esperando o devedor por prazo indefinido, fizeram essa
publicação por edital para contar o prazo ali
de 15 dias que ela teria para pagar.
Como a Fabiana não pagou, averbação 19, consolidação
da propriedade em nome do Santander, e aí
o Santander vai realizar o primeiro, se ninguém
arrematar, o segundo leilão.
Finalizou aqui, então, tudo certo, né?
Consta ali a informação de que a Fabiana
foi notificada, consta a consolidação da propriedade em
nome do credor, tudo certo quanto a isso.
Partindo aqui, então, para o edital.
O edital, ele é bem parecido, até porque
é do mesmo banco, né?
Você sempre leia com atenção.
Aqui a gente vai dar uma passada mais
rápida para só recapitular os pontos.
Data do primeiro leilão, data do segundo leilão,
nome do leiloeiro, que é um leiloeiro oficial
da Junta Comercial de São Paulo, número de
inscrição, endereço, leilão realizado de forma presencial online,
ou seja, leilão híbrido, dados do credor, dados
da devedora, o valor do primeiro leilão, o
número da matrícula desse imóvel e do registro
de imóveis que está localizado esse imóvel no
Rio de Janeiro, toda a descrição que tem
que bater sempre com a descrição da matrícula,
nesse caso está batendo, cadastro municipal, de novo,
que é uma venda em caráter ad corpus,
ou seja, você está comprando um imóvel pelo
imóvel, não vinculado especificamente à metragem dele e
no estado de conservação que se encontra.
Caso não haja licitante em primeiro leilão, segue
para o segundo leilão com lance igual ou
superior a R$ 303.186,10, que
seguindo a Lei nº 9.514,97, é
o valor da dívida mais encargos.
Coloca aqui para os interessados em comparecer presencialmente,
coloca para os interessados online, fala da habilitação
com antecedência de até uma hora da data
do leilão, fala do pagamento do valor da
arrematação e da comissão do leiloeiro, também a
comissão do leiloeiro de 5%, direito de preferência
do devedor, fala da desistência do arrematante da
multa de 20% sobre o valor da
arrematação e comissão do leiloeiro.
E aqui, no primeiro leilão, o valor do
lance mínimo será nos termos do parágrafo primeiro
do artigo 27 da Lei nº 9.514
,97, ou seja, o valor da avaliação ou
o valor venal, o que for maior.
No segundo leilão, será aceito o maior lance
oferecido desde que igual ou superior ao valor
da dívida, das despesas, dos prêmios de seguro,
dos encargos legais, inclusive tributos e contribuições condominais,
ou seja, IPTU e condomínio serão pagos até
a data do leilão.
A gente já viu que IPTU não tem
nenhum débito.
Se, por acaso, o edital passasse a responsabilidade
do condomínio, como você iria levantar essas informações?
Entrando em contato com o próprio condomínio.
De novo, colocar aqui o endereço no Google,
colocar também o nome do condomínio para facilitar.
Consegue aqui o telefone, liga para lá, diz
que é interessado no leilão, que precisa saber
os débitos já que o edital está passando
a responsabilidade para quem arrematar, não é o
nosso caso aqui desse exemplo, se fosse você
usaria essa informação.
Use também esse mesmo número para saber quem
está morando no imóvel, quem está ocupando, se
é o devedor, se é um locatário com
contrato de locação com o devedor, se o
imóvel está desocupado, faça sempre essa verificação.
O edital depois segue para falar que o
registro é por conta do arrematante, depois fala
de evicção, dos prazos, tudo normal, depois leia
com atenção.
Vou passar aqui de uma forma mais dinâmica
já que a gente analisou o outro leilão
de forma bem completa.
Algo bem importante para fazer sempre é analisar,
deixa eu abrir o edital aqui de novo,
é analisar se existe algum processo do devedor
contra o credor.
O imóvel no Rio de Janeiro, então TJRJ,
já que não é um contrato com a
caixa.
Vamos buscar aqui pelo nome do devedor, copiar
aqui do edital que fica mais fácil, Fabiana
Martins de Souza.
Buscar os processos que a Fabiana tem aqui
no Tribunal de Justiça do Rio de Janeiro.
Primeira instância, todas as comarcas, competência, civil, ano
inicial, vou colocar uma janela bem grande aqui,
mas depois a gente descarta de acordo com
o ano da compra desse imóvel pela Fabiana.
Nome da parte Fabiana, pesquisar.
Apareceram 14 processos da Fabiana aqui de 2000
até 2021.
Vamos ver o ano de compra aqui para
a gente já eliminar vários desses processos.
A Fabiana comprou esse imóvel em 2018.
Então vamos eliminar aqui todos os processos que
são antes de 2018.
Aqui 2005, não.
2009, não.
2017, não.
17, não.
18.
Começamos aqui em 2018.
Fabiana contra lei empreendimentos imobiliários, não é o
que a gente está procurando.
Condomínio up barra mais contra a Fabiana e
a academia contra a Fabiana.
A gente não tem nenhum processo aqui contra
esse réu aqui que é a capa empreendimentos.
Então só aproveitar que a gente está aqui
para ver esse processo que o condomínio up
barra mais estava movendo contra a Fabiana, porque
é esse condomínio aqui do leilão up barra
mais.
Então provavelmente a Fabiana não estava pagando os
débitos condominiais e o condomínio entrou com esse
processo para cobrar o que era devido.
Como a gente tem no edital a informação
de que o valor do condomínio será quitado
pelo credor, esse processo ele já deve ter
uma baixa pela quitação da dívida.
Vamos só confirmar essa informação.
Toda vez que você abre um andamento do
processo, clicando aqui no cantinho, a gente consegue
listar todos os movimentos.
E a gente consegue ver a sentença, porque
a regra é que o processo é público.
Então vamos abrir aqui a sentença.
É uma sentença que diz que na petição
de Folhas 89 foi requerida a extinção do
feito em virtude da quitação do débito e
foi promovida pela parte requerida.
Então o processo ele vai ser depois que
transitado em julgado, ou seja, que ninguém vai
oferecer recurso, ninguém vai oferecer recurso já que
a dívida está paga, ele vai ser arquivado.
Então a consequência dessa dívida aqui é exatamente
aquilo que a gente viu no edital, já
que o credor vai passar ao imóvel livre
de ônus de IPTU, que a gente viu
que realmente não tem débitos de IPTU e
também livre de débitos condomínio.
Então esse processo aqui que foi movido em
2019 pelo credor de IPTU condomínio contra a
Fabiana, a dívida foi quitada, muito provavelmente, pelo
Santander, que é o banco que está levando
esse imóvel a leilão.
Então também tudo certo da parte da documentação,
a matrícula consta de relação judiciária, consta consolidação
da propriedade, consta a notificação que a Fabiana
foi notificada para purgar a mora.
No edital as informações batem com a matrícula
do imóvel, consta a data do primeiro e
do segundo leilão, o valor mínimo, a informação
lá que os débitos de IPTU e condomínio
são quitados pelo credor até a data do
leilão.
A gente conferiu que realmente não tem débitos
de IPTU, não tem débitos de condomínio e
nem precisaria dessa conferência a mais, já que
o edital, ele sempre vai valer e o
edital está falando que os débitos serão quitados.
E a gente também viu como levantar informações
do ocupante com o número aqui do próprio
condomínio, ligando para o condomínio.
Então, desse ponto de vista, tudo certo, pesquisamos
lá os processos.
O que você precisaria se atentar seria realmente
a viabilidade financeira.
Faça a pesquisa do valor real de mercado
desse imóvel, veja se te interessa.
Sempre faça isso em todos os imóveis que
você for participar e assim você pode participar
dos leilões excruciais de forma segura.
Sempre siga esse checklist, o arquivo está disponível
para fazer download aqui nessa aula.